[Music]
in the studio adam granducille leader
and songwriter of the war on drugs is a
sculptor of sound i try to just keep
chipping away at
you know this little idea you may start
with
work on something for
seven eight months
and eventually it just kind of like
turns into something
[Music]
it's turned into unexpected success for
the indie rock band whose last album
lost in the dream sold more than a
quarter of a million copies
growing up in massachusetts grand ducey
always loved music but his passion
deepened when he picked up an electric
guitar at a friend's house i remember
hitting this red washburn and like the
ground shaking
i knew actually when i did that i was
like this is the greatest
single greatest moment of my life grand
ducey was living in oakland in 2003 when
he suddenly moved to philadelphia in
search of a music community
you took a leap here
coming out here i didn't know what else
to do really at the time he took
part-time jobs at first i was a bouncer
if you can believe it for a while a
sports bar
at a sports bar yeah
were you a good bouncer no i let
everybody i love everybody
[Laughter]
but in philly he found a kindred spirit
in musician kurt vile that little window
like 2004 through like
2010 or 11 was probably the most
inspiring time of
my creative life for sure um
i think we were both kind of like
feeding off each other's like
like what we were
both searching for you know
they started performing together as the
war on drugs at a local bar johnny
brenda's so you guys used to play here
all the time yeah we started playing
here when they opened the upstairs we
were the first band to play after the
band's first album via left to pursue a
successful solo career
but the war on drugs following has grown
with each record
[Music]
a few months ago grand ducey found new
rehearsal space in an old technical
school in south philly so what were you
looking for when you moved in here
i we i needed a place i could like i had
some of my gear out in los angeles i had
stuff in storage units the band stuff
was all over the place right
i needed a place where like everything
could be in one one spot
and the band could rehearse and
get inside the music and just a place to
grow you know
their fourth album a deeper
understanding is also their major label
debut i guess the only thing different
with this record was i knew that
there was a little bit of an expectation
about it how did you interpret what that
expectation was i just knew i needed to
like push myself to a place where
i felt like i went all the way